Yeah. We still have no cluster DNS.
Cube DNS has endpoint.
Okay. That's after eight.
Yeah.
Let's see if Guy wants to come in
and give us a last bit of advice
before we we wrap this up.
Are we close?
You've you've not looked at the configuration of
core DNS. You've looked at the pods, but
not how the pods are configured to run
the DNS.
We have the DNS.
Yeah.
Just keeps coming.
Alright.
Did we miss something?
Let's let's I'm gonna say cheat. Let's I'm
gonna jump onto cluster 14
and grab the config map and see what's
different. What
about
Yeah.
These are the exact same fail.
So he told us to look in the
core DNS config and then there was nothing
wrong with the core DNS config. That's just
cruel.
I was saying there's a few pixels.
This is a white space error in the
core DNS config. I will be may be
frustrated.
It might not be a white space error.
He's mocking us now because he said you're
jumping back and forward showed a slight difference.
This number seems arbitrary. Oh, you son of
a bitch.
I'm assuming
there's like a weird bug and I'm sure
he's found it because he works at Skyscanner
and they've got a level of scale that
most people don't have.
But
something to do with this number going so
high is maybe causing it to load an
old config map in the pods or
something. I don't really
know.
But the number being so high worries me.
But we're now at the stage where I
have to go and pick up my daughter.
So
Yeah. I'm just gonna bring Guy in to
tell us what wonderful magical What we should
do. Is. Yeah. Alright, Guy.
Lay on us.
So
when you were jumping back and forth between
the working config and
the non working config,
if you look really hard at the c
in front of the in the Kubernetes config,
Oh, you bastard.
The c?
Yeah.
It's not a c.
No. It's character which looks a lot like
a c.
What? So the Kubernetes plug in became authoritative
for
letter that looks like c luster.
Local.